thank you
[Music]
I wanted to talk about this because it's
going around on Reddit and I wondered if
you guys have experienced a similar
situation
um people are kind of talking about
situations where they go and eat at a
restaurant with friends or just with
people they know um and then once the
bill comes
certain people start having to go to the
bathroom or they walk outside go for
smoke do little things that gets them
away from the bill so that someone else
kind of gets stuck having to figure it
out has that ever happened to any of you
guys really that's no some I mean like
in high school the thing I liked about
hanging out with Asian gangs is that
they were just like their parents where
they would always try to pay for the
bill it was a sign of like it was like a
power move you know like hey I'm gonna
so it was nice but at the same time it
taught you a lot because like if you do
those things
they're gonna confront you and they
might even be aggressive toward you
because they're like why the [ __ ] you
never paint or like you know so then so
then it was like a more in your face
approach to it and then after a while I
was like oh yeah but people also also
take care of each other because like
let's say someone just got out of jail
and then they can't go back home and
they just take care of them and you take
care of them until like they take care
of you so the I guess that system in
high school that I learned like up until
College I didn't mind if people did that
but it was also a good way to see
someone's character so let's all go out
to eat and if someone keeps doing that
then I take note of it in my head and I
know what kind of person they are but
what about all the viewers that don't
have prison friends I
[Laughter]
cons a lot
although like everybody
that's what I was thinking too like as
Asians like growing up I always
remembered all my Asian friends would
always want to pay I didn't have to
worry about that yeah but then when it
came to non-aging friends they were a
little more like how do you want to do
this yeah not that they were trying to
skip out on the bill but I have had that
happen one time oddly that we went to go
eat at at The Loft uh in in uh in
Lakewood and then
um this one girl she was like this one
white girl from my uh Community College
came with us and then when the bill came
she just kept like kind of like zoning
out and like kind of doing her own thing
and then eventually I was like
what's the deal like what are you doing
and then she was like oh I only have two
bucks oh [ __ ] then why'd you come why
did you [ __ ] order it
that's her nickname was Deuce we used to
call her deuce
because oh what's up deuce
what's a lop which is
like in dollar plate is she about two
bucks yeah it was a heavy taxes just to
have a nickname for the rest of it I
think there's some people that literally
will go eat with you with the assumption
that you will pay and they don't even
come prepared it's it's weird when they
do that when like most people are just
up front you know they're like oh [ __ ]
but hey can you cover me like oh yeah
yeah but then when it's afterwards and
you're like
I'd be more embarrassed to try to hide
it like to me it's it's it's less
embarrassing to be like I really did
forget my wallet or like let me try to
venmo you or like I would tell people
straight up back in the day when I was
broke I'd just be like I'm broke man I
can't go eat with you like that yeah
like dude you could afford a [ __ ] 15
meals like I'm out here trying to get
Costco hot dogs for a buck 50 and then
and then they'll be like I'll take care
of you you know you guys go to Costco
no we go to Taco Bell well meet in the
middle you know yeah but that's the
other thing right it's like if you say
hey let's go here and then the homie
goes ah
I'm broke bro I can't go there then it's
either I'll cover you or we'll find a
cheaper place yeah that's the way it
should be and I think when you were
younger that was a lot more casual and
easy to say yeah I think when you were
in high school like at least when I was
I would very easily go I don't got the
money for Denny's like we gotta go to
Jack you know like stuff like that you
were just very open you know what I
would do this is what I would do when I
was in college
when I was with like a you know like a
your hyung figure you're older you know
and they oftentimes do take care of it
so you get into this like you hope you
know what I mean okay you like hope yeah
I'll just slowly take care of you know
take out my wallet or slowly take just
see if they already do this move you go
oh where's my wallet no oh man oh I
don't know where it is but if it's like
a young like I I feel like I just try to
thank them before the bill even come
like sincerely because hey thank you for
paying for me man
thanks for covering this man I
appreciate that it means so much that
you take me out to lunch when I cannot
afford it
yeah if they're young somebody's younger
and then they pay for yours not like
that though
thank you foreign
or like a thing the older brother will
pay for you it's nice sometimes uh even
if you're older person you want to pay
for a younger person it's really nice
you feel good too and they feel good
then and I think if you thank them
that's really nice do you think there's
something that ties like all Asian
culture together in this like exchange
mentality stupid pride no like um I
think it's more being a group being like
a harmonious group I think I was
chilling with some Armenians or Eastern
Europeans one day at the old restaurant
I used to work at and I was like oh this
is very similar to Asian culture the way
that they were like they do it exactly
and no one was like oh we gotta do it 50
50. no it's like the older guy was
taking yeah this time next time I do it
yeah yeah yeah and then I was like
there's there's a lot of cultures like
that but it's different from like maybe
it's like cultures that are more
collectivist versus individual you know
what I heard in Germany everybody pays
their own meal nobody goes paid for me
or or I'll pay for it never happened no
but really everybody's like half half no
yeah just I'm gonna pay for my shoes
that's crazy Los Angeles Asians it's
like it's like hey I'll I'll pay for the
bill I'll pay for the bill because I
want the points on my credit card but
just venmo music
that's a great move Doug you win this
time next time is my credit card you
venmo me yeah yeah yeah but also like I
think
and um like the way I saw it was like
okay I might pay for the bill but then
they'll give me something else like
either in value or like or like I don't
know they'll be thoughtful about
something yeah yeah and then we all kind
of wire to do that like yeah like where
it's like yeah someone's covering it
because they have the most money but
then I I'm gonna help them out some
other will go to work yeah it feels it's
just it's like a potluck like you just
bring different dishes but if you're the
guy that always brings [ __ ] napkins
then everyone's like the [ __ ] is wrong
with you dude they have kids when I
started hanging out with other cultures
it was interesting I remember uh
remember those two twins that were at
College the roller skaters yeah yeah
they um who are these people that's what
what character they're like they're like
professional rollerbladers or some [ __ ]
like these two twin are they Jewish yeah
two twin hot juice studs yeah so imagine
two dudes that look like straight up
models
um and they both like rollerblade and
[ __ ] grind on [ __ ] and the amount of
each other's dicks yeah
the amount of nickel and diming they had
between each other was crazy wow yeah
yeah they're like I only have this well
then you're not I guess you're not gonna
get the nachos I'm like you don't just
cover the brother like a dollar no
remember that one guy in uh he used to
he used to work for barbell and it was
so funny because he was like he when
when the bill came he was like no no no
no no this is I'm Jewish I have to do it
this way we have to do it oh they can't
post it out a calculator yeah yeah and
then he's like and then I think we'll
tear them apart yeah one of the guys
were like no no I'll cover you don't
worry he goes no I have to pay my way in
and he's like everyone pays their own
way really similar to what you see your
parents do yeah I've always seen my dad
fight to pay the bill or just like pay
for it before anybody can yeah so then I
thought I could [ __ ] do the same [ __ ]
whether I had money or not I was just
trying to do that but I feel like
because that's what's right in your mind
yeah Anthony was saying earlier that I
feel like some people do it because of
love but some people I think do it
because of Pride yeah Pride's a big
thing yeah yeah I had another Homie we
had a bat and the bat was so so
something so stupid it was just a like a
one dollar iced tea I lost my coolest go
to McDonald's to get you like a sweet
tea goes no no we're going to Ralph's
I'm like what and then he went inside
and bought the gallon Arizona Iced Tea
and I was like
I guess some cultures really want to
maximize the win I was like all right I
was like really I know it's Pride let's
collect I know it's pride and I know I'm
guilty of it because sometimes I think
that I'm supposed to like cover the bill
because it's respectful even if they're
like Elders or something like you know
you go to the business meeting or
somebody like no let me take care of the
bill but even in that business meeting
it's like I know you're so much richer
and more yeah yeah but I have to do this
yeah you know what I mean and and that's
like uh one of those funny faults you
know that it's like you're you for sure
can pay for this and I am like I need
your business but I'm still gonna do
this because for some reason I would
subconsciously taught this yeah yeah
there was a time where uh so when we
used to go out with Redfoo all the time
and uh he would always just pay the bill
for the bottle service the table service
everywhere we went right and then
towards the end we just assumed like no
one would ever even gesture oh I'll pay
two or yeah a lot of people we would
just not make a thing out of it and then
uh eventually once he went like solo and
then we were kind of just like we went
to Toca Madera all the time right oh and
then we would go at night before the
clubs but then we would have a bunch of
girls that would just join our table and
start ordering [ __ ] and he didn't like
that because that's kind of rude to just
do that right you're not sucking
nobody's dick and you don't even know
anybody
that's not a proper thing to do like you
don't just go like go Sonos table I'll
have the [ __ ] stake in this and order
all this [ __ ] so then um one night he
was like I'm not gonna pay this bill oh
and then so the bill came and that uh
and then I thought it was really smart
I'm like yeah what are these girls gonna
do like these like three girls they just
started doing that and then the bill
came and then we all like gave them
their separate bills and then all of a
sudden they freaked and these are like
girls that look they're dressed in like
Rich ass [ __ ] yeah and they look like a
million bucks and they turned into the
most peasant [ __ ] villagers you could
ever they went oh God I don't um Can
someone else like cover this because I'm
I'm still waiting on like a check and I
don't really have yeah so funny three of
them were giving different excuses all
what was each person's bill
um it was like about a meal like you
don't have to talk about their prices
there's like about a meal big yeah but
they weren't eating with us they just
came to sit with us to like flirt and
then ordered food so we were like oh
here's your bill I don't even know your
name here's your
and then some other guy had to pay for
them because he
yeah some other dude was just like you
know what I don't want to like hear this
anymore so I'll just pay there's always
a sip that's ready to go did he get did
he go home with them that night no they
did he just we just wanted to go home
ourselves so we're like rather than just
sit here and talk because it was kind of
like an experiment we were like it was
red tear laughing just so yeah we were
just like dude this is so crazy that how
many times could this have happened in
the past yeah because we that was
happening all the time I think it's nice
that he did it once so that to check
everybody yeah don't do this because
they weren't friends of ours they were
just like kind of hanging and then uh
that's the same thing with that they
call them bottle rats when you go to the
club and you get a table and then all of
a sudden all these girls come to your
table and they start drinking your
alcohol and then they scatter when the
lights turn on like roaches yeah exactly
and when the last one on too they're
butt ass ugly but you thought they were
fine yeah yeah let me ask you guys do do
you guys like the gesture though like of
pulling out the wallet I I would say
this the empty gesture I appreciate that
though I don't want the empty gesture
like I I personally yes no uh you are
you saying when you gesture or when
someone gestures when somebody he's just
sharing when you're paying I don't know
I think either way is kind of weird if I
if I genuinely want to cover it then
you'll win no it's not even that it's
just like it's fine dude like don't
worry about it like don't even gesture
I'll cover it like when they go hey I'll
pay for it and then you look down and
it's like a Rite Aid card and then you
both laughing idiot and then you pay for
it when people pay a receipt yeah
anything a driver's license
if that's how your relationship is with
that person if you consistently go out
and then sometimes you pay sometimes
they yeah and then it's like okay and
they're pulling out it's like that's not
a gesture that's like an actual action
right okay yeah
well you can also figure out little
games like what we used to do to figure
it out in high school was we would put
the card at the edge of the table and
then you flick it up and then you try to
catch it in your fingers like this and
if you can catch it then you get to pay
but if you drop it you can't pay then
you get to pay then you get to pay
that's like you literally go like this I
couldn't catch [ __ ] oh I suck at this
game scissor catch it like that I want
to try that yeah
they said it's the Korean way to pay
really but the fool just [ __ ] made it
up so we believed it was Korean for
years that's so funny catch and then you
can be like that that's Ty that's so
cool I got that coordination but the
funny thing is I I started doing that
with everything right and then I thought
it was cool to whenever I checked a new
hotel and the lady gave me the key she I
would go like this thanks and I'd walk
away you're the coolest guy but then one
time I I hit it so far it slid under her
counter and she was like why would you
do that
[Laughter]
let's follow the structure of who should
pay like in family so like for us it
would be all this uh working all old is
working but sometimes so for example my
stepfather he was like Hey I want to
treat you guys out for dinner if he says
that and he goes choose whatever you
want then no one's gonna put up a fight
oh yeah if he calls it he's retired yeah
yeah that's true it's like but I just
feel like bad but it's respectful yeah
yeah and then
um typically like like now I'm at the
age where like I can pay my own way and
like maybe I might make more or whatever
but then I still respect the hierarchy
of like if they want to take care of it
yeah I'm just going to let them do it
but then sometimes I will do it two just
to be like hey I'll take some of the
burden so it's not like the whole day
you're paying three meals if we're like
on a trip together or whatever right
yeah but like I feel like when you're in
your 30s and on you should start paying
yeah yeah like I think like maybe in
your 20s still you could get away but
still like I think now like the the
power shift will change depending on you
if you start becoming like 30 with kids
and you're growing then like your your
parents you're gonna take care of like
you know there's that shift that happens
the shift yeah taking care of you
because most Asians don't have a a a
like like a retirement program like the
way that like you know they their
retirement program is you letting them
move into your house and you take care
of them yeah no nurse nothing right yeah
it took me a lot to learn
um and I didn't learn this until much
later when you get older and your
parents are trying to offer you things
or give you things and then you're like
I don't need that mom like come on
exactly and like it's respect to accept
it and just act like oh my God like
thank you I can't go straight to a trash
can
the [ __ ] am I gonna do with this
you don't do that though for sure you
see a lot of stuff yeah but you know you
know the respective if like if the the
Elder respect if they tell you hey I'm
gonna pay today you order what you want
you also have to enjoy it you can't go
yeah oh this sucks like yeah like you
don't make comments right do you if
somebody pays like an elder or whatever
do you guys like um order less things
hell no I do it to my heart's desire
dude if I know anyone else is paying
yeah in general even if it's a friend I
don't order the [ __ ] tomahawks yeah
dude I try to for sure I try to get less
just because it's you know I just always
feel like I'm guilty of like not paying
like if I'm going out and someone covers
it with family or just in general
everybody even when tip is like I want
to take you out I feel guilty do you
feel guilty when I used to buy you
breakfast as a thank you for training me
yeah I'd be like no because you're
giving me a free service but it's not
even that it's just like I feel like I'm
cheating you because you should get paid
more for the time time that you've been
training me and I get away with buying a
15 [ __ ] egg and steak Yeah but it was
good steak and eggs uh it's like but
it's but that like if you do it a couple
times I'll be like oh thanks Joe and
then the [ __ ] up thing that I do is
like if Joe would be like hey you want
to go get steak and eggs I'll be like no
I'm good bro I'll be back now but I
enjoy that or why don't you just say
let's go but the new page yeah or
something like that I'll try to but then
I know sometimes it's like this
[ __ ] won't even let like there's
certain people that won't let you pay
you know what I mean and it's like that
[ __ ] bad but I feel like for me
though I'm actually getting a bargain
like I feel like I'm cheating him
because I pay 15 bucks for what should
be like a hundred dollar training
session hey we should go back to getting
steak and eggs though that place is
still yeah but then that's how I filmed
you that's all I think you felt guilty
so you had to hire him full time
when he pays you
40. take an extra training are you
training him a 15 value just to get
breakfast yeah I'm just like yeah dude
just do whatever yeah
hit the back for an hour yeah yeah you
can squat I guess I don't know this guy
fights like steak and eggs
foreign